things are getting a little shady around
here don't you think
all right joining us here on the rich
eisen show um is a two-time super bowl
champion in back-to-back years as a
matter of fact how about them apples so
he knows quite a bit about the chiefs
and the bucks and so much more and andy
reid he is none other than sean mccoy
how are you doing sean
what's up man how you doing i'm sorry
i'm good i'm i'm sorry i'm late for you
but i was just prattling on about how
excited by the divisional round that i
am you know hey you're absolutely right
i think it's some great talents
you talking about josh allen man you
talking about uh pastor mahomes it's
gonna be a crazy game i'm excited to
watch it all right what is let's start
first with the one of the guys that uh
you know very well um what is andy reid
telling his team
this week before championship game what
is he like
leading up to the big game
if i know indy read well and i think i
do yes you do he's telling his guys on
defense she's challenging him he's going
to tell him like hey man i got a guy
over there by the name of josh allen
right
and he's dominating right he's gonna
step up to the challenge and make plays
force turnovers things like that make a
tough one and then on the offensive side
he's gonna make a bigger challenge he's
gonna tell pastor mahomes hey
who's the bigger dog
in the afc
right who's the better offense they got
stephon dixon we got tyrek hill we got
travis kelsey he's going to find a way
to motivate his guys and and get us to
compete at the highest level so that's
something he's always been big at so are
you saying he's walking around with a
little bit of the needle he's already
saying he's needling these guys a little
bit you know what people know about
coach reed man but
like he loves to um
to get his guys going to compete you
know to get him going and go on there
and unless he has a bigger deck he
always talks about that
how do you do that with you
i mean anytime like we would play
different teams and and um
are you are you the best player back in
atlanta fan are you like stuff like that
you know to give me going i remember
in the game right i have a pretty good
day probably like third quarter you know
up he's like hey are you done that's
that's it that's all you got
so he's always finding ways to motivate
his players
really and so
the first time he did that to you
did you think he was like trolling you
in a way or like what did like how did
you take it the first time you ever did
something like that oh
it's like you know coach reid is like
he's he's one of my favorite coaches of
all time um
you know one thing about him he always
has the players back so you know it
comes from a good place he's having a
good he having fun with it um he has a
bigger personality with the media knows
and what he shows so i know he's always
just you know mess with me
i love that i mean just you know he i
mean he he shows it a little bit
sometimes but usually only he's talking
about food you know what i mean like
that's that's usually the time when he's
showing all that i've got the burgers no
doubt about that lashawn mccoy right
here on the rich eisen show here on nbc
sports on peacock and also nbc sports
audio on siriusxm we're back here on the
rich eisen show terrestrial radio outfit
joining us here lashawn mccoy on the
rich eisen show so uh what is bruce
arians
telling everybody right now
now that you know what it's like playing
for him what do you think is going on
with aryans there
right now
i think what um being an excellent coach
i was so surprised how well of a coach
he was i heard a lot of greatness about
him so
one thing about him is um he also makes
challenges right um you know i think
when he makes his challenges
he's a lot more serious he's a lot more
direct um one thing about va man is that
i love this he's a coach that he doesn't
hide his emotions doesn't hide his
thoughts or feelings he's he's straight
up you know feelings is on the table
and i'm sure he's telling his guys right
now hey man it's a big challenge you
know the rams are talked about they can
get a lot of um changes and additions in
the off season to be where they're at
right now so
the defensive line you know you got to
step up
make staff for uncomfortable and their
offense hey me got some guys down you
know i was hurt
you got the best quarterback and best
player to ever play the game and tom
brady so what are you guys going to do
what's your good what's your brady story
you got one for me the one that that
pretty much sums up what he's like to
play with teammate with or on the field
with you got a good one for me
one day um
i was just in a bad mood right
um i wasn't getting like a certain place
i want to get right in um
hey hey let's do some some extra routes
and normally i always do it you know i'm
always trying to perfect my craft and
once i'm like oh no i like wave it off
when i shut my head
i was like hey shady because i think i
heard him shady not like wait what but
he came to say hey man you know let's do
some extra rounds
we kind of left you know the practice
field
he came to me and grabbed my arm he said
hey man should do something you do it he
said i ain't he said i'm not telling you
do something i won't do right
i'm like damn it's a real leader right
there
so that's one of my tom brady story he
let me know hey look man
the way i got to this level is not by
that it's about you know perfecting the
craft and keep going
so why were you upset again why were you
i was just upset because i wanted i
guess one of the plays i was supposed to
get i didn't get i think they gave them
somebody else it wasn't like i like a
little moment you know hey moment
so he just checked me man it's a team
thing you know
so in that moment you didn't just strip
down and run off the field and quit
no i let you know i actually left my
shoulder pads on okay
and it was at practice
all right
but
no but i just kind of find it
interesting that you know you you got
down because you thought maybe you
weren't getting the rep or you weren't
getting the snap you weren't getting the
look you weren't getting the the target
and brady's the one coming up to you to
say let's let let me
get you through this with the extra reps
here
to make sure you're sharp because he
he's he knows and you did too deep down
i mean you're a pro i mean you're you're
not on the all-time teens list you know
in the nfl for
for nothing
you know too that you could be called at
any minute and that's the route you have
to run to win a game you know what i
mean like that's the way it works yeah
it's well it's about being a
professional that's the nfl and then we
have our roles in the end of the day
we're all trying to win super bowls and
i i think when we go back to i'll give
you one one more story yeah um
everybody was talking about tom speed
right so like the last couple of weeks
he was like spring
so they set up they set up
they set up a a race because he's so
competitive right
right he said well look i i'll race
whoever you guys in the race some guys
made a joke so they brought up one of
the coaches now the coach was like do i
receive a coach i won't say his name but
he knows in shape
and i play football
and i think tommy beat him
to show you look man look i could do it
all so that's the children's competitive
nature that you already hear about read
about well i know he
he tweeted out where he instagramed down
a a shot of him catching a football on
the sideline that was thrown errantly
and he grabbed it out of the air you
know like and this is the sort of stuff
that he wants to let everybody know and
you know because again uh
we keep talking about his
accomplishments in terms of his age
because we've never seen it it just
doesn't compute you know what i mean it
doesn't it does not compute and now
comes this uh this game this week
where
you know
which two guys being out do you think
matters more uh
jensen and worfs up front or godwin and
brown not in the pattern what do you
think well wait so so the two llama are
out well i'm just
it's not official but the guys haven't
practiced all week even if they get out
there on friday i mean that's a that
might be the most grown-ass man
in the history of the nfl
coming up the middle of that defense you
know like so even if they do play you
know you know there won't be a hundred
percent
so
that's yeah that might be the biggest
difference you know why why um since
i've been there the last this year or
lat last year i'm sorry and then this
year just being a part of like all my
friends and my guys
they've been the most healthiest
offensive line group i've been a part of
right and um if you know brady he's in
tune with his linemen right yes um ryan
is like extremely smart
and um he kind of runs that show and
then tristan is probably the best
lineman
i mean he has great feet he's a
superstar in making the things he's done
this year
it's it's like
i mean it's not surprising so knowing
that that's probably the biggest i think
issue would be the linemen if they're
out because that's a great group they
know each other well they know the plays
they like to do well they communicate on
another level so them two not playing
that would be dangerous for the team
sean mccoy here on the rich eisen show
prior to divisional playoff weekend um
which uh team
[Music]
in tennessee cincinnati or the titans
would you be most concerned about
coming out the team that's number one
with a huge lift and we assume it's
derek henry coming back
like derek henry or this young team that
really doesn't know what they don't know
in a way and don't care
to know it like the bengals which one's
more dangerous to you do you think i'm
going i'm going with the young gunners
man
i like what i call them the barrel crew
i love what they're doing they're young
they're explosive they have that i don't
care attitude even in his second year
joe barrow is emergency one of the
biggest stars
um then you look at probably one of the
he's the best
rookie wife i've ever seen in jamar
chase really um
i like i like them i like joe mixon in
the backfield
um t higgins is in there and then my
guard caller boy from pittsburgh holding
it down i love that group i think
they're dangerous because
i remember just playing as a youngster
right not knowing who's the real good
guy
and just playing and reacting to when i
knew who everybody was
like okay you're playing against ray
lewis let me watch out for 52. you said
i'm saying you just go out there playing
so right more damage to me
yeah i i mean i i think that's funny so
you know the wiser you got the less
risky you've got basically is what
you're saying in the nfl
i think like
this the smarter you got it got easier
but also you're just more aware right
you just more aware
if
you're younger you're just running the
gun and then you're not aware
you might take a big hit because you
just didn't you didn't see it coming you
know it was coming you know you're just
playing balls to the wall just going out
there give it all you got um
you know but i think you're young gun
man you just you take
you take them dangerous risk
so i look at the quarterback where
i'm young and um i'm gonna try to throw
that ball in the needle start the needle
and get it in there compared to the
older vet that's knowledgeable that
knows a little bit i might not change it
let's show them the questions
mccoy here on the rich eisen show okay
so you won two years ago with the chiefs
you won last year with the bucks
if we could wave a wand and say you get
a phone call from somebody saying join
or or you get a phone call from somebody
say you could join any of the eight
teams left
so you could have a shot at a third ring
in a row one of those rare moments
which team would you choose you have
your choice
you could go on any of these eight teams
which one would lashawn mccoy choose
because you feel you could go back to
back to back
if i had that decision and choice yes
sir i would start start off like this
back to back i'm going with the bucks
i feel like they have the best
opportunity
you do uh
i look i i i chose the bucks okay i
chose the bucks
prior to last year and i got off them
i'll be honest with you the way that
your team looked going into thanksgiving
that was the week in which you lost to
the chiefs but we saw what happened
after that right
um
and i got off you and i i swore i would
never get off of a tom brady quarterback
team ever again if i thought they had
the chance to win and i chose him before
this season
and i haven't gotten off him despite
being given a mulligan by the nfl
network crew on thanksgiving and yet
last week
but the guys injured up front really
really make me nervous
lashawn
yeah man that that's the biggest thing
if
if some guy's hurt that's gonna be tough
for him right for the team but one thing
about brady man like just being one of
like he's so aware of everything so
when they're getting pressure on him
right you can't blitz him because he's
gonna be ready for that
um
you know the only team i've ever seen
really plays really well because they
match up well this was on the saints
just because they got the guys up front
yeah and they got the guys in the back
end right but
when i look at the rams i don't think
they don't have that right you don't
think they got to go home a second i got
jalen ramsey on an hour number three
lesean i don't want to get him upset oh
i mean i mean he's one but that's one
guy like that's he's listen listen
i mean he's by far the best corner in
the league but i mean he's a whole
secondary you see what i'm saying i was
i'm sure tom's gonna stay away from him
right because i would right and then
he's gonna he's got he's got his tight
ends now right he's got
got the other young guy see tom knows
like he's all about match-ups so okay
ground was hurt and he's a hell of a
player and a b is not playing he has
other players with other abilities so
he's gonna go for the match-ups got the
running backs got the tight ends running
from next plan
so they he he's gonna make it happen and
tom with a line in it if they're banged
up
he still finds his way like okay now
my reason to be quicker right the play
calling has to be a little quicker now
longer play actions like
this guy is different he's a different
dude in the playoffs you know this
i do that's why i'm not getting off him
again
but the time and lastly yeah all the
talk about the belichick i'm happy it's
over because
it's brady i'm trying to tell you it's
really braided 12 that does all that
magic not belichick now they can see it
for their own eyes
now that they separate with the
championship and now the time's still in
the playoffs still making noise
come on home second wait a minute you're
saying come on belichick doesn't do
nothing you you're like it's all it was
all brady the entire time
that's what you're saying i can't say
all right but i mean it's more like
more like 60 40 you know 60 40.
i'm being generous
including the times when tom was
starting back you know before you even
were playing
when you were you're when you were a
twinkle in the pittsburgh panther eye
you know what i'm saying
desean even then
even then like like
when he got with tommy the whole
everything changed i mean you see the
stats the numbers before that was it
that before tommy wasn't wasn't with his
man was no dynasty and then you then you
leave tommy and you get the most point
score ever in a in a playoff game they
have not one fourth down that's crazy
scoring every possession is that what
that that matters right yeah no i i see
her but i i mean
i i just had a push back a little bit
there look i mean i i believe in tom
just like everybody else but
you know no you choose them you wouldn't
choose the packers at all like they're
you you're like a brady and the packers
make it and brady goes back there you
were there last year you saw it i
think they'd do it again right
and they're gonna do it again i just
think that they match up well so i'm all
i'm big on match-ups yeah right yes
because i think they're well coached
va's like a real really good coach
um
you know i think that the packers
they're a complete team too but
look at both sides like on defense i
think that the bucks they played aaron
rodgers really really well solid
secondary okay get a lot of pressure on
him he's got your pressure on aaron
rodgers without sending the heat
right
because if you do you're going to
like dissect everything right and i
think the bucks do that well get
pressure with no blitzes
okay you know so
we will see i could be wrong i'm never
always 100 right i'm just more like 89
89
right yeah
that's for me
leave him alone stop it leave me let me
know
89. that's right 89 percent right lesean
mccoy i've never heard that one before
but thanks a call lesean you be well i i
miss chatting with you let's do more of
this dude more often
one of my favorites man for sure yep
right back
thank you right back at you that's
lashawn mccoy right here
on the rich eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here